Now that we found the balance after the first 2 years, it would be great if we
could find it even further along in time. Let's work right now to find the
balance after 3 years. Actually, you already did this earlier, but I'd like us
to write it in this kind of notation. We start with this amount, since that's
how much money there is at the start of your three. And then, the amount that
we need to add to this in interest, is just this quantity times 0.03. If we
factor out this quantity from both terms, then we end up, once again, with 1
plus 0.03, inside this second set of parentheses. However, since we have 1 plus
0.03 squared here, times that quantity again, 1 plus point 0 3. We can make
this look more compact, by changing our exponent up here. Instead of squared,
this is cubed this time. Now that we have another quantity continuing our
pattern here, what do you think about the guess that you made just before this?
Do you want to keep it as is, or do you want to change it? Think about what
pattern you see. Think about what you think the exponent in each of these
expressions means, and then use that information, that pattern to write down
the balance in this form after 4 years, after 10 years, and after 100 years.
I'll also give you another chance to write down your hypothesis. You can write
in exactly what you wrote before or you can change it this time, taking into
account the new information we have now. Once again, this part won't be graded.
We are, however, going to see how your numbers look.